romrod mit globetrotter damm spezialist
für niedrige rat gibt globetrotter punkt
ca
ich bin im nordosten indiens scheinbar
nader kamangar der dritthöchsten berg
der welt
der schilling ist wohl das berühmteste
tv gebiet der welt zahllose plantagen
säumen die hügel der familie des
großgrundbesitzers radschab energy
gehören seit vier generationen
teeplantagen zu seinem reich gehören
heute nicht nur diese berge sondern auch
eine teefabrik und ein ganzes dorf in
dem seine arbeiter wohnen bevor mich bei
energy sein reich betreten lässt beginnt
er mit einer segnung lass mich dich
meinem gott vorstellen
und das ist ihm der priester alle
verletzungen der menschen sind auf eine
gestörte harmonie zurückzuführen canepa
ist der gott der weisheit er schärft
unser bewusstsein
granitza segne dich
mögest du viele wunderbare jahre haben
[Musik]
unsere reise begann in kunming im süden
chinas
die olma roth führte uns nach myanmar
bis in die hauptstadt ihren von dem
ehemaligen rangun entlang arten
handelsrouten bereisten die us-armee
norden indiens nach nottuln island
erreichen wir bei schilling auf der tour
durch die berge besteht der patron
darauf das auto sie einmal selber zu
fahren
sie haben das unter kontrolle ja ja ja
alles unter kontrolle
ich wollte nur sichergehen nicht dass
sich kein vertrauen hätten
es ist eine maschine wenn man sie
richtig behandelt ist alles unter
kontrolle
[Musik]
traditionell ernten ausschließlich
frauen teeblätter ihre hände sind
kleiner und flinker als die der männer
erklärte bellucci
denn für spitzen t werden nur die zarten
obersten blättchen vom strauch gepflückt
eine anstrengende arbeit darum sei es
ihm wichtig die frauen gut zu behandeln
wir pflegen eine partnerschaft wir leben
seit vier generationen zusammen
sie haben auch ein recht aufs land sie
sind meinem partner ihre angestellten
sind ihre partner
ja wir leben zusammen sie sind meine
partner sie sind nicht meine arbeit ich
bitte sie
wir mögen uns und sprechen viel
miteinander
anita lama kam nach der schilling um
einen job zu finden und geld zu
verdienen aber die arbeit gefällt ihr
nicht sie ist anstrengend und eintönig
unter lohnt tief sagt sie ich kann
nichts anderes machen als drücken
das ist das einzige was ich gelernt habe
leider gerne würde ich etwas anderes tun
aber das ist nicht möglich
oft schon haben die eltern und
großeltern hier gearbeitet der nati
betont dass erfahrung fördern will
das ist unsere erste weibliche
vorarbeiterin mehrere tv das ist aber
vom schweizer fernsehen
sie waren die erste weibliche
vorarbeiterin das war die reaktion der
leute
wir frauen managen haushalt erziehung
der kinder versorgen die männer also
sind wir doch fürs führen gemacht wir
können das sehr gut wenn man uns lässt
energy zahlt seinen frauen pro tag 120
gruppen 85 etwas mehr als der standard
lohn für gering
dann gib mir banerjee einen crashkurs in
t kunden das wichtigste ist der boden
die erde
das wachstum der pflanze der zeitpunkt
der ernte und natürlich hilft das
spektakuläre biotop in dem der tvv
wächst dass die geely oder darjeeling
ist nach acht stunden bringen die frauen
ihre ernte zur teefabrik mindestens zwei
kilo teeblätter wissen sie jeden tag
drücken bis vor kurzem dabei sagen
straff abzug weil sie die vorgaben nicht
einhielten
für jedes kilo gibt es umgerechnet einen
abend zusätzlich darjeeling tee wird an
den börsen zu höchstpreisen gehandelt
bis zu 1800 franken pro kilo
die arbeiterinnen habe nichts davon der
lohn reicht kaum für das nötigste sie so
bezahlt ein soziales unternehmen den
tipp für thüringen zur tiefen sie
schauen nur auf die zahlen
dabei vergessen sie all die
zusatzleistungen ihre wohnung ist gratis
medikamente sind gratis wir essen und
ihre kleider sind kostenlos die schule
die versicherung kosten nichts
auch das benzin ist gratis so verdoppelt
sich darum
niemand schaut sich das genauer an aber
ich weiß worauf sie hinauswollen
auch so gibt es nur einen franken 80 pro
tag ich finde das auch zu wenig darum
dürften die frauen nun zimmer an
touristen vermietet
so können sie sieben bis acht mal mehr
verdienen als ihren mindesten
nach der arbeit holt töpferin garni
tanaka ihren sohn von der kinderkrippe
ab diese stellt der packung zur
verfügung
anita lebt mit ihrem sohn in einem ein
zimmer haus sie kann keine anbieten und
so ihren lohn aufbessern
ihr mann hat ihm jede rabatt weit weg
arbeit gefunden
für ihren sohn erhofft sie sich ein
anderes leben ein wunsch ständig immer
wieder höre auf meiner reise die arbeit
die wir machen ist hart und oft haben
wir schmerzen
wir wollen nicht dass unsere kinder das
auch erleben müssen
ich möchte dass mein sohn eine bessere
ausbildung bekommt unseren kindern soll
diese arbeit erspart bleiben
[Musik]
bianca unterrichtet freiwillig in einer
schule in darjeeling sie arbeitet für
einen traum von einem besser neben für
die kinder einmal pro woche vermittelt
sie den kindern die grundwerte kleines
richtigen lebens schließt die augen
[Musik]
naja wir lehren die kinder mit allen
religionen zusammen zu arbeiten und
niemanden zu diskriminieren
moslems sechs christen und buddhisten
alle religionen sind gleich sieben
dieselben gebote er unterricht beruht
auf den leeren eines kubus der hier
verehrt wird im westen aber umstritten
ist
was sind die fünfte ist die us army
gelehrt hat die pflichterfüllung
disziplin entschlossenheit keine
diskriminierung und hingabe
ohne diese fünfte ist sind wir
unvollständig als menschliche wesen
müssen wir diese 5d s befolgen priyanka
wie mit ihren lektionen mithelfen dass
die kinder menschen mit schlechten
absichten erkennen lernen
[Musik]
da schilling ist eine magnet für viele
immigranten viele kommen aus der noch
engeren nepal
sie suchen arbeit menschenhändler nutzen
das außen versprechen lukrative jobs vor
allem auf junge frauen haben sie es
abgesehen
nicht selten landet diese später in der
prostitution in katar beinahe wäre jan
kah locker von solchen skrupellosen
schleppern geworden
mit der unterstützung einer ngo versucht
sie nun menschenhändler zu überführen
wie sie das macht erklärt sie mir bei
unserem treffen in zeitungen fahndet sie
nach stelleninseraten in denen junge
frauen gesucht werden
sie gibt sich als stellensuchende aus
und versucht herauszufinden ob das
angebot echt ist oder als vorwand
benutzt wird um arglose frauen in eine
falle zu locken
die jungen frauen wollen natürlich geld
verdienen und das leben genießen
sie rufen also an und wenn das inserat
nicht echt ist können sie in der
prostitution in also mehr herausfinden
will muss man anrufen ja so habe ich es
gemacht und gesagt ich mache alles um
geld zu verdienen mit ihren
nachforschungen hat priyanka bereits
zweimal den handel mit frauen verhindern
können
nachdem ich alle gespräche aufgenommen
hatte über habe ich sie der polizei
die können damit arbeiten es ist
beweismaterial
ihre arbeit bringt vier jahren kein
gefahr und zivil lieber nicht in der
öffentlichkeit wir weiter sprechen wo
unsere kamera auffällt im haus einer
freundin erzählt sie mir ihre geschichte
die nachbarin aus ihrem dorf versuchte
sie an schlepper zu verkaufen aber
bianca kam dahinter und rief ihren vater
zu hilfe
es gelang ihm aus den fängen der
kriminellen gruppe zu befreien
sie verkaufen diese jungen frauen und
verdienen damit viel geld damit prahlen
sie im dorf herum geld verdienen kann
man so oder so sexarbeit prostitution
und menschenhandel wird man reich aber
um ein ehrenwertes mitglied der
gesellschaft zu sein und die welt besser
zu machen muss man hart arbeiten
ehrliches geld verdienen das hat viel
größeren wird franka will polizistin
werden sie hofft dass sie so noch mehr
frauen vor menschenhandel bewahren kann
[Musik]
unsere reise führt uns zur letzten
station nach kolkata dem früheren
kalkutta der hauptstadt von westbengalen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im zuge des drückend heiß stickig und
eng
70 grosse befüllt und da sitzt da wir
müssen trotzdem muss ich einige morsche
ausziehen das fühlt sich noch viel mehr
fühlen
[Musik]
wir nähern uns cook hatte hier leben 14
bis 15 millionen menschen so genau weiß
das keiner
pro katar ist neuland für mich die stadt
so laut und chaotisch seien für
asiatische großstädte ist das nicht
weiter ungewöhnlich und nach zehn jahren
in asien fühle ich mich in der hektik
und dem wirbel zu hause
aber bei allem was ich hier war katar
gehört habe weiß ich nicht was in dieser
stadt auf mich zukommt
denken sie an besser dort taxis die nach
englischem vorbild in indien produziert
wurden sehen aus wie eh und je
liebevoll wurden die könige der
englischen straßen genannt
aber auch könige können nicht verhindern
dass wir baut im stau stecken bleiben
war schnell irgendwo hinfahren das gibt
es nicht in dieser stadt
schon nach wenigen minuten ist die stadt
nicht herum zu einem großen parkplatz
geworden
widerstand ist zwecklos mitschwimmen im
rhythmus der stadt ist die einzige
chance
[Musik]
schaut man crew katar beim erwachen zu
ist das fast zu intim wie dieser mann
schlafen hunderttausende im freien auch
frauen und kinder
das badezimmer und die toilette ist der
fluss nahe der auerbrücke dem
wahrzeichen der stadt
auch die rikscha fahrer mango katar ist
es zeit aufzustehen
diesen neun quadratmeter großen raums
teilt er sich mit 40 anderen rikscha
fahren
hier dürfen sie nur wenigen
habseligkeiten deponieren und das wasser
nutzen schlafen dürfen sie hier nicht
für diesen lager und bezahlt mango
chutney 30 rappen im monat
zardaris 42 jährig er hat eine frau und
drei kinder
sie leben 500 kilometer von hier in die
haare
dort ist die armut allgegenwärtig nur
als wanderarbeiter in der stadt kann er
seine familie ernähren
münchen sind lauf rikschas stasi hat
beinahe aus dem straßenbild verschwunden
nur hier in kolkata gibt es sie noch die
stadt wollte sie zwar verbieten aber
mango katar und seine kollegen wehrten
sich für sie ist es die einzige
möglichkeit geld zu verdienen
an guten tagen verdiene er drei franken
am tag als schlecht nichts sagt er
es gibt viele probleme der arbeit ist
hart
ich muss die miete für die rikscha
bezahlen und die kunden stänkern herum
aber so ist es halt
für seine familie nimmt er das schwere
leben auf sich in kolkata ledig seit 20
jahren ein nachbar im dorf hat mir
gesagt ich solle hierher kommen
jetzt muss ich hier bleiben es gibt
nichts anderes nur einmal im jahr kann
er sich einen besuch zu hause leisten
und so bleibt er in der stadt und macht
weiter
katar gilt als armenhaus indiens
den mittellosen menschen hier bleibt
nichts anderes als das leben und
manchmal auch das sterben auf der straße
[Musik]
aber es gibt auch die andere seite
erfolgsgeschichten wie die jenes
jungunternehmers der sich hier im süden
der stadt im modernen viertel ein
imperium aufbaute abi shek runter musste
nach einem fahrrad unfall lange im bett
liegen als zeitvertreib spiel sehr mit
dem computer unentdeckte die it branche
für sich mit applikationen nach trotha
heute viel geld angefangen hat er mit
fünf angestellten
heute arbeiten 600 für ihn er ist noch
immer im gleichen büro wie vor 17 jahren
aus aberglauben zieht er nicht um andere
erfolgreiche jungunternehmer zieht es in
die großen wirtschaftsmetropolen indiens
nicht so viele unternehmer die karriere
machen wollen zehn weg nach delhi oder
mumbai aus welchem grund viele menschen
verlassen kolkata weil sie anderswo eine
intakte natur und bessere jobchancen
haben
das liegt auf der hand kolkata musste
aufholen
25 jahre lang waren hier eine hochburg
der kommunisten
damals war die finanzwelt verpönt nichts
erstrebenswertes sympathische punkte
fordert von seinem team leitern
umsatzziele ein welchen umsatz kannst du
mit einem kunden in den nächsten drei
monaten erzielen
5000 5000 5000 ist ein ziel für die
nächsten drei monate
gleichzeitig sucht das gespräch mit
seinen mitarbeitern und unterstützt das
sie selber denken und kreativ sind
regelmäßig zeichnet er den mitarbeiter
des monats aus denjenigen mit dem
meisten umsatz
gratulation gut gemacht runter startup
steht für den unterschied zwischen
chinesischen und indischen
unternehmertum
es gibt zwar sehr unterschiedliche
modelle china mitteilung statt
kapitalismus der sehr erfolgreich ist
wenn man das wachstum an schaut auf der
anderen seite das doch eher chaotischer
unternehmertum in indien welches glauben
sie ist das bessere modell um ein land
vorwärtszubringen und wieso kurzfristig
sieht das modell von china lukrativ aus
schnelles wachstum kopieren aber
längerfristig bleibt die innovation auf
der strecke indien hatte als demokratie
große vorteile
china ist gut in der verarbeitung aber
das können wir auch doch innovation
hingegen kommt aus der kultur
und zwar indischen kultur gehören
natürlich auch die täglichen fernseh
songs die sich millionen von menschen
anschauen
ich fahre nach toleranz einem stadtteil
von kolkata wo sich zahlreiche
filmstudios niedergelassen haben in
unzähligen serien verkaufen sie dem
publikum inszenierte träume und
illusionen
[Musik]
hier weht ein hauch von bollywood diese
kategorie ist ein quotenrenner in der
hauptrolle eine frisch verheiratete gut
ausgebildete frau die nicht nur hausfrau
sein will sondern das leben genießen
will gedreht wäre es täglich wie am
fließband mit 400 angestellten
hunderttausende junger frauen in
westbengalen verehren die
hauptdarstellerin und die rebellische
figur die sie verkörpert buchautorin in
lima dank opatija ist das hirn dieser
geschichten
sie kennt jede figur und erinnert sich
an jede folge obwohl es schon mehrere
hundert sind
das drehbuch liefert sie frisch aus
einem büro um die ecke 12 stunden
schreibt opatija jeden tag an vier
serien gleichzeitig inspiration findet
sich im alltag sagt sie es ist für mich
immer wieder interessant zu sehen wie
die leute diese geschichten mit dem
richtigen leben verwechseln
ihr assistent bringt das abgedeckte
manuskript im studio
zwei tage später wird eine neue folge
über die rebellische frau gedrängt wo
ist heute der platz einer jungen
indischen frau die frauen in allen
geschichten weinen nicht
sie kämpfen gegen widerstände und für
ihre sache
sie sei sich ihrer verantwortung bewusst
sagt sie darum wurde sie vor allem
starke frauen zeigen in unserem land
werden viele frauen unterdrückt und das
fernsehen ist eine möglichkeit darauf
aufmerksam zu machen die frauen zu
ermutigen gegen solches unrecht zu
kämpfen und sich für sich selbst zu
wehren dass million geschafft
gesellschaftliches bewusstsein wäre noch
immer die männer
[Musik]
im leben einer jeden indischen familie
hat die heirat einen hohen stellenwert
zur heirat gehört immer noch die mitgift
und die üblichen form von gold die liebe
zum gold hat in indien lange tradition
in katar bestehen ganze straßenzüge aus
gold geschäften
[Applaus]
die kleineren juwelierläden haben oft
noch eigene werkstätten die den schmuck
mit einfachsten mitteln herstellen
in den wirklich teuren läden dürfen wir
nicht filmen
[Musik]
doch am nächsten morgen finden wir einen
familienbetrieb der uns empfängt schmal
das führt das goldgeschäft in sechster
generation und zeigt mir hochzeits
colliers im wert von umgerechnet
mehreren tausend franken
in der indischen hochzeitssaison wenn
die wohlhabenden familien ihre töchter
verheiraten
steigt der goldpreis an der börse den
handel mit mitgift gibt es immer noch
die familie des schwiegersohns übt oft
großen druck auf die braut familie aus
auf die braut nur in unser haus bringen
wenn du so und so viel bezahlt bis heute
ist das so aber das zahlen von mit
geboren 1961 offiziell verboten
das ist ganz übel wir verurteilen solche
deals nicht nur in den dörfern wird es
bis heute gemacht sondern auch in den
städten machen dass einige familien
immer noch
manchmal werden die frauen wegen der
mitgift sogar umgebracht
was tut ein vater wenn er den
forderungen des bräutigams nicht
nachkommen kann
entweder bringst du deine tochter um
oder sie bleibt unverheiratet das aber
gilt als schande
die leute werden versuchen dich und
deine familie zu quälen und
einzuschüchtern
[Musik]
aber ist es inzwischen nicht besser
geworden
ja jetzt ist viel besser geworden
immer land wo übertreffen der
mannschaftssport konto hat ist wohl die
einfachste form gut ist enorm wichtig
wieder hochziehen
die soziale stellung von familie zeigt
sich nämlich darin wie viel goldschmuck
breiter tag vor der hochzeit als mitgift
familie bringt vergütung ohne
goldhochzeit tethering
[Musik]
wir sind in einem typischen mittelklasse
quartier in katar familie verzockt haben
im sichersten schrank haben sie ihren
goldschmuck verwahrt die mutter legt ihn
für die tochter bereit die heiratet
schmuck im wert von 600.000 rupien über
9000 franken kam so zusammen
seit der geburt ihrer einzigen tochter
haben die eltern dafür gespart
es ist eine art sicherheit von unserer
seite für unsere tochter einen teil des
goldes bleibt in ihrem besitz auch wenn
es du eine trennung käme es ist eine
sicherheit akzeptiert die 24-jährige
wird mehrere tage lang feiern mit vielen
traditionellen ritualen
[Musik]
heute kommen weibliche verwandte und
freundinnen der braut zusammen tochter
rosa bekommt die letzte mahlzeit aus der
hand der mutter und wird symbolisch
gefüttert
[Musik]
von jetzt an ist der erhebung für die
tochter zuständig ein emotionaler moment
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit in der wohnung des
bräutigams an und bald schon da ist 27
und lebt mit seinem bruder und dessen
frau zusammen eigentlich würde auch
seine mutter hier wohnen aber sie
arbeitet in dubai und ist jetzt nur zu
besuch
wie die braut wird auch der bräutigam
symbolisch zum letzten mal von der
mutter geschützt sie segnet ihn und er
erweist ihr zeigen respekt
diese traditionen haben unsere vorfahren
überliefert alle müssen sie befolgen bis
heute obwohl wir diese tradition in
teilweise nicht verstehen müssen wir sie
bei aller beachten denn das alte
brauchtum nicht sehr wichtig im haus der
braut dreht sich alles um die hochzeit
[Musik]
rot ist die farbe des glücks roxas
freundinnen helfen ihre fußsohlen brot
einzuwerben eine typische bengalische
tradition
rot ist die farbe der gott hat karl und
gut für die ehe
ich werde morgen heiraten
es ist ein ritual das ist alles wird
noch weiter geschmückt beide arme der
braut werden mit henna bemalte
auch die freundinnen werden verschönert
für die braut ist jetzt der moment den
ganzen goldschmuck anzulegen
dann heißt es stundenlang stillsitzen
für das make up das ist wasserfest die
tränen werden reichlich fließen
ich bin sehr gespannt auf mein neues
leben
es ist doch sehr bewegend
[Musik]
habe ich noch meine familie verlassen
diese gehen jetzt montag
auf diesem thron in der gemieteten
wedding hohe wird die braut drei stunden
sitzen und glückwünsche und geschenke
entgegennehmen
traditionell richten rutsches eltern das
fest aus hübsch ist ihre einzige tochter
nur die die selbst eine tochter haben
können das verstehen
mein herz ist schwer dann treffen die
ersten gäste ein
[Musik]
die braut kam sich in ihrer vollen
pracht präsentieren
[Musik]
der bräutigam ist noch nicht da
ein paar stunden später kommt er ist
nach genauen vorschriften gekleidet die
schwiegermutter und die tanten richten
hannover für seine braut her und jetzt
fitter die schwiegermutter ihm zum
ersten mal
seine frau sei perfekt sagt er während
des fotoshootings ihre persönlichkeit
der umgang mit menschen das ist auch
wichtig für unsere ehe sie hat einfach
alles
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der moment wo sich das paar
zum ersten mal gesehen hat früher aus de
noch von den eltern arrangiert wurde
das ritual ist heute noch fester
bestandteil der feier
[Musik]
aber cooper und albert haben sich ganz
modern im internet kennengelernt
sie gehen zusammen aus aber sex vor der
ehe ist noch immer tabu mit dem tuch das
er über die hände des paares legt
übergibt der brautvater hübscher ihrem
mann das feuer ritual macht die ehe
rechtskräftig
der casino scheitel macht hübscher auch
gegen aussen zur verheiratete frau die
[Musik]
familienfeiern noch bis spät in die
nacht das große ereignis
einige zeit später besuchte ich rutsche
und an opap in ihrer gemeinsamen wohnung
ich bin neugierig mit den beiden das
neue leben gefällt und ob wuchs mit
ihrer rolle als hausfrau zurechtkommt
aber die beiden fangen sofort von ihrer
hochzeit zu schwer gewesen
sie zeigen mir das farbenprächtige
hochzeitsalbum hochzeits königin fast du
dich wie eine königin gefühlt ja ich
fühlte mich wie eine königin
alle beachteten mich und alle brachten
geschenke und wünschen viel glück
vor und während der hochzeit aber später
als du ins haus eines mannes gekommen
bist es braucht etwas zeit alle
familienmitglieder mussten sich erst
daran gewöhnen
ich weinte ständig damals jeden tag
es braucht seine zeit bis sich alle
familienmitglieder daran gewöhnt haben
aber jetzt läuft es gut ich hoffe für
immer die richtige entscheidung
er ist ein sehr fürsorglicher
verständnisvoller und liebevoller mensch
das ist gut für mich denn ich bin sehr
aufbrausend er aber bleibt ruhig und
sachlich
ich fange immer gleich zu streiten und
er beruhigt mich er macht mich sehr
glücklich sagt sie machen sie glücklich
und umgekehrt
ja natürlich ich habe mich verändert und
habe nun eine viel größere verantwortung
vor der heirat war ich junggeselle und
machte was mir gefiel
nun will ich nur noch machen was ihr
gefällt
sie macht mich natürlich
bevor ich arbeiten gehe legt sie mir die
kleider bereit sie kocht das was ich am
liebsten mag sie macht alles was ich mag
und das immer besser
ich wünsche mir dass wir das ganze
ähnlich sind und was wünschen sie sich
von ihrer frau ich wünsche mir dass sie
so bleibt wie sie ist
trotz ihres neuen lebens als hausfrau
schaut hübscher noch immer am liebsten
die soko zagora die geschichte einer
hausfrau die keine sein will
hier endet unsere reise
[Musik]
zeit für mich heimzukehren
nach hongkong
ok
china limitiere einmal mehr realisiert
was mich von außen zu faszinieren
gelandet
smartbooks andere inspiriert haben
anschauen aber gekauft und wieder groß
vorrangig ist sehr schwer
manschetten vor chance erarbeitete
programm zum besten
im dorfklub und vorderen hat
die wende nach oben
[Musik]
foto marud mit globetrotter und fernweh
ist die wahl siebte bis achte november
im kursaal bern fernsehfestival punkt ch